welcome back guys two most amazing top
ten my name is Danny Burke and today we
have got the top ten most common
disorders these mental health disorders
we're going to be talking about might
not be all that visible at times but
they're just as serious as any physical
illness now I try to take the top ten of
these and put them in some sort of order
and as ever the best place to start is
of course at Number ten and we've got
schizophrenia it can be found in less
than 1% of people but one study found
that perhaps 7 to 8 percent of people
will experience it at some point in
their lifetime the word schizophrenia
literally means to split the mind
sufferers often hear and see things
aren't really there as they lose touch
with reality months before any visible
signs appeared to anyone else sufferers
have odd feelings and thoughts that lead
to criticizing voices in their heads and
delusions in the beginning a person with
schizophrenia is able to separate these
experiences from their real lives but as
time goes on these inner thoughts begin
to affect their actual lives all right
next up now for our number nine we have
Tourette's now - Rhett affects less than
1% of people and is a condition where
people have uncontrollable tics they
will repeatedly show either motor tics
or vocal tics sometimes both basically
involuntary physical movements such as
blinking or sudden jerks of the body
such as the shoulders or the arms vocal
tics and when a person makes an
uncontrollable noise and this can be a
totally random noise like a humming or a
no coughing noise or something or
sometimes it can be a word or a phrase a
lot of symptoms are first noticed in
childhood a lot of people tend to have
an easier time as they get older and are
able to live normal lives next up from
number eight we have OCD now you
probably heard people casually say they
have obsessive compulsive disorder but
the estimated two percent of people who
really do suffer from it would disagree
sufferers have obsessions and
compulsions to do things over and over
again that they believe will protect
them from harm perhaps in some way but
realistically has no effect these
rituals can be anything from repeatedly
checking the door is locked to insisting
that things are organized
a very specific way or having to touch
something over and over again people
with OCD sometimes strive for such
perfection in the task they are doing
that they end up taking hours and hours
just do the simplest of things obviously
everyone has worries in life and habits
but when they get in the way of your
life and you feel that you don't even
have control over them that's when it
becomes OCD moving on that's one number
7 we have bipolar disorder now being
bipolar means a person experiences huge
swings in mood motivation and energy
when they're up there feeling great the
thing energized and they can be very
social and talkative but when they are
down sufferers struggle from a feeling
of hopelessness and often lose control
of their eating and sleeping habits it
affects an estimated 1 to 3 percent of
all adults and the average age of a
sufferer is about 25 years old
now some people are treated with
medicine that tries to stabilize their
mood while others take part in talk
therapy this focuses on dealing with the
thoughts that accompany the highs and
lows in the hope that understanding them
might help people to control them next
up number 6 now we have psychosis now
this is a disorder that affects roughly
3% of people and tends to occur mainly
in adolescents psychosis is essentially
a loss of touch with reality it happens
in episodes that can last a few days or
maybe even weeks during which the
sufferer is often confused hallucinating
and extremely paranoid now I actually
did some work experience when I was
younger working with young people who
have psychosis and for the patients I
can tell you these episodes are very
real and very intense
they often sense things that aren't
really there such as hearing disembodied
voices that leave them not trusting
family their friends or even the doctors
who are trying to help them moving on
that's one number five we have eating
disorders mountain 18 disorder is any
eating habit that has a negative impact
on the body and affects about 3% of the
population the most common types are
anorexia which is an obsession with
losing weight by refusing to eat and
bulimia which involves overeating
followed by self induced vomiting this
sort of binge eating and purging means
that eating disorders are one of the
deadliest of all with mortality rates
being about 12 times higher for those
with it than without the vast majority
of eating disorders are found in women
particularly in adolescence a lot of it
is blamed on the media and society's
portrayal of an unrealistic body image
for women as people strive to be like
the models on those magazines chimerism
before now we have general anxiety
disorder now this is the most common
anxiety disorder and affects an
estimated 3 to 5 percent of people
sufferers have an almost constant but
unrealistic worry about everyday events
these worries can be about anything
really about money their health their
family's health maybe the future just in
general school and work and it can end
up stopping the person from functioning
on some days so they try to avoid
whatever is causing their anxiety
general anxiety disorder actually
affects twice as many women as it does
men and scientists think it is down to
stressful life experiences brain
chemistry and it can be handed down
genetically from parent to child alright
moving on to our number three now we
have depression man oppression is
probably one of the better-known
disorders out there but it's much more
than just that feeling of being a bit
sad one day three to five percent of
people suffer from depression and it's
symptoms of hopelessness own motivation
and just a general lack of interest in
life they can affect the person's
ability to function on a daily basis and
they may struggle to work sleep or even
eat sometimes persistent thoughts of
death or suicide can lead to suicide
especially in young people where it's
the second leading cause of death in 15
to 29 year olds there are effective
treatments out there that help millions
of people fight depression and
thankfully a lot is being done to raise
awareness that depression is not just a
bad day it's a very real serious but
also treatable disorder all right come
here number two now we have PTSD
now post-traumatic stress disorder is
thought to affect up to 8% of the
population as a name would suggest it's
a disorder that comes after a person has
experienced some sort of traumatic event
in their life whether it's caused by a
life-threatening moment early in life
abuse or often war PTSD symptoms include
nightmares
anger and flashbacks about that event
and also an emotional detachment from
people and life in general as a way to
protect themselves from the traumatic
memories and finally in the warned now
we have ADHD it stands for attention
deficit disorder and affects mainly
children with some 11% showing symptoms
between the ages of 4 to 17 ADHD
sufferers by it difficult to concentrate
pay attention and comply with authority
figures those are basically the three
things you have to do at school so it's
no surprise that it becomes a very
obvious disorder in the classroom those
with ADHD show signs of hyperactivity
and can be very impulsive it's actually
three times more likely to occur in boys
than girls the good news is that certain
medical and therapy treatments have
proven to be very effective in treating
ADHD and a majority of children do grow
out of it eventually despite this though
scientists are yet to fully understand
all the causes of it alright guys that
was that top 10 most common disorders if
you learn anything today don't forget to
hit that like button that would be great
and if you want to see any of the
sources I use for this video and perhaps
learn more yourself they're all down
there right down there in the
description box so check that out if you
are suffering from any of these
disorders we've talked about today or
maybe if you feel you might be
experiencing some of the symptoms talk
to someone I can't stress that enough
find the right number or website out
there and get in touch with someone who
can help you it's always okay as ever
thanks for watching guys I hope you're
having a lovely day my name is Danny
Burke I'll see all of you guys soon